Hi, this is Taryn from
Somerville, Massachusetts.
Radiolab is supported
by dash digital cash,
the quick and easy way to send money to
anyone in the world from anywhere in the
world.
Dash arrives within seconds
and transactions are instant
secure and optionally
private dash is digital
cash. For more information,
visit dash.org/radio lab. Hi
Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Squarespace
launching their new campaign.
Make your next move, make your next
move and set new goals for this year.
Locked down your next move idea with a
unique domain and create a website to
launch today by using offer code Radiolab
for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website.
Make your next move with
Squarespace more@squarespace.com
hey, it's Molly Webster from radio
lab. Before we get into the show today,
I wanted to tell you something and that's
it. Radiolab has a newsletter we do.
It's awesome. You should sign up for it.
You'd be the first to
know about new episodes.
You'd get updates on old ones
and lots more to sign up.
Go to radiolab.org/newsletter see ya.
Okay.
You're listening to radio lab from New
York public radio, public radio, W,
C, n, n. P. R.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Some people go to therapy, some to church,
others come here to the northwest
corner of a parking lot on fire island,
where most nights you'll find
a handful of people looking up.
I come down here quite often.
It's a great place to stargaze.
You've got the sound of the ocean in
the background with the crashing waves,
stash the relaxation of it. You
know, the night I visited this guy,
Ron was about one of 20 enthusiasts,
huddled over astro maps,
staring through telescopes of all
sizes is quite a quite a telescope,
some so big and needed a ladder. Wow.
That's a big cluster of stars. Yes,
it certainly is. Do you get
attached to certain stars? Oh yeah.
Yeah, yeah. You did. You get begin.
You know the first one
she ever found and stuff.
Do you remember your first walk?
Yeah. Beerio was one of my,
I really like Ron's gonna show
it to you at MCAP. You can do it.
I didn't catch your name actually. John,
what it is that to the naked eye yet?
A just those like a
really famous single star.
But when you look at it through a
telescope, Zen look in there. Yeah.
Oh my God, they're so bright.
Lights like through the telescope.
Al Berio looked like a headlight. Bright
and flat and close. Very immediate.
But that was nothing compared to
what happened next. A woman walks up,
points her finger at the
star. Okay, so is it,
is that the one up here and
touches it? That one right
touches the star. That's really cool.
That was one of the things. It's
describe what you just did please.
I a turned on my green laser
and I pointed at the store.
It was one of the coolest things
I have ever, ever, ever seen.
Her name was Linda. She had a pen that
was a laser. When she turned it on,
a focused bright green beam of light
sprung from her hand to the star like a
long green finger.
She literally touched the star and for
a moment I forgot the ground underneath
my feet. And at that star Iberia
was 50 million light years away.
It seemed right.
[inaudible]
so tell me what you mean. What do you
see when you look up besides you know,
nebulous and and stars and star clusters?
Well what do you sort of look for exactly?
Well can really see sorta like where you
are in the universe or at least in our
own galaxy.
And it makes like a very interesting
perspective for yourself.
You know,
and like what life is like here and what
life must be like in other worlds and
whether or not there's other planets
out there with people or different life
forms that we came to comprehend.
This is radio lab on Janet
from Roger Today on a program.
We're going to project our minds out
there to the great beyond and asked some
basic questions here to help.
As always a hi is Robert Krulwich
and in this hour we discover how big,
oh sorry we and in this hour
we find ourselves in space.
We discover how immense, how huge
space is and then we ask ourselves,
now where does that leave
us? We are a Spec on a Spec,
on a Spec, on a speck,
and his astrophysicist,
Neil digraphs Tyson will
remind us later in the program.
It is difficult for little
specks like us to find walking,
talking intelligent spec
somewhere else in the universe,
but say what you will be, are
trying, speaking of which,
let's begin by rewinding the
clock back to 1977. Okay.
This is the big year for the space
program because in August of that year,
NASA launched a spacecraft carrying
a gold record. You remember this,
right? I remember the record carried a
message from us to them. Our story now,
it was Carl Sagan,
cosmos is all that is or
ever was or ever will be.
Who led the team that made the record.
And that team included actually was headed
by Annie Druyun and visited Annie at
her home in Ithaca, New York.
And we sat in the backyard near a
waterfall in the same spot. She says,
where Carl would sit
and become so absorbed in what he was
reading that he would not notice a deer
standing right next to him. My
name is Annie Durian. And, um,
it was honored to be the
creative director of the voyager.
It just stellar message project
which began in early 1977.
But now how does this come about?
I think about the project now and
it's so exciting to think about,
I mean it's such a romantic idea
that you know, that at the time,
absolutely we felt,
first of all that this was
a kind of sacred trust that
here we were half a dozen
very flawed human beings with the huge,
a huge holes in our knowledge
of all of these subjects.
Building a cultural Noah's Ark.
It was the chance to tell something of
what life on earth was like two beings of
perhaps a thousand million
years from now because the,
the voyager engineers were saying this
record will have a shelf life of a
billion years. That didn't race goosebumps
then you'd have to be made of wood.
Uh, it was also the, the, the,
the season that Carl Sagan and I fell so
madly in love with each other and here
we were taking on this mythic challenge
and knowing that before it was done,
two spacecraft would lift off from the
planet earth moving at an average speed
of 35,000 miles an hour for the
next thousand million years.
And on it we'd be a kiss,
a mother's first words to her
newborn baby. Come on now,
Mozart
[inaudible]
NATO.
Greetings in the 59 most
populous human languages.
Hello for your children or planet earth
as well as one non U in language,
the readings of the humpback whales
and it was a sacred undertaking because
it was saying we want to be citizens of
the cosmos. We want
you to know about that.
[inaudible]
tell me about the moment you
fell in love with Carl Sagan.
You said it was during the
voyager compilation? Yes, it was.
It was on June 1st,
1977 I had been looking for some time
for that piece of Chinese music that we
could put on the voyager record and not
feel like idiots for having done so.
And um, I was very excited
because I'd finally,
I found a ethnomusicologist at Columbia
University who told me without a
moment's hesitation that
this piece slowing streams,
which was represented to me as one of
the oldest pieces of Chinese music,
2,500 years old was the piece
we should put on the record.
So I called Carl who was traveling,
he was in Tucson,
Arizona giving a talk and we had been
alone many times during the making of the
record and his friends for three years.
And neither of us had ever
said anything to the other.
We were both involved people.
We'd had these wonderful
story in conversations,
but we hit both,
been completely just professional about
everything in his friends and he wasn't
there. Left a message.
Our later phone rings pick up the
phone and I hear this wonderful voice.
Then he said,
I get back to my hotel room and I
find this message and it says any cod.
And I say to myself, why didn't you
leave me this message 10 years ago?
And my heart completely skipped a beat.
I can still remember it so perfectly.
And I said, for keeps. And he
said, you mean get married?
And I said, yes. And we had never
kissed. We had never, you know,
even had any other kind of
personal discussion before.
We both hung up the phone
and I just screamed out loud.
I remember it so well because
it was this great Eureka moment.
It was just like a scientific discovery.
And then the phone rang and I was
thinking, oh gosh, you know, like,
and a phone rang and it
was Carl. And he said,
I just want to make sure that really
happened. We're getting married, right?
And I said, yeah, we're
getting married. He said, okay,
just wanted to make sure. And um,
spacecraft lifted off on
August 20th and August 22nd,
we told everyone involved.
And we were together from that moment
until his death in 1996 and December.
Wow.
Talking about romantic Michael Magic
and part of my feeling about voyager
obviously,
and part of what I was feeling in
the recording of my brainwaves,
my heart, my eyes, everything in
that meditation on the record,
I had asked Carl whether or not would it
be possible to compress the impulses in
one's brain and nervous system into sound
and then put that sound on the record
and then think that perhaps
the extraterrestrials of
the future would be able to
reconstitute that data into thought.
And he looked at me and beautiful
May Day in New York City and said,
well, you know, that was a million
years is a long time. You know,
why don't you go do it?
Because who knows, you know,
who knows what's possible in a
thousand million years. And so, um,
my brainwaves and rem,
every little sound that my body was making
was recorded at Bellevue Hospital in
New York.
This was two days after Carla and
I declared our love for each other.
And so what I often think is that
maybe a hundred million years from now,
he goes, somebody flies that record down,
and I always wonder it because part of
what I was thinking in this meditation
was about the wonder of love and of being
in love and to know it's on those two
spacecraft. Even now in my,
whenever I'm down, you know,
I'm thinking it's still, they
move 35,000 miles an hour,
leaving our solar system for the Great
Wide Open Sea of interstellar space.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
billions of years from now,
the Sun will have reduced this
planet to a charred ashy ball.
But that record with Andrew,
Ian's brainwaves and heartbeat on it will
still be out there somewhere intact in
some remote region of the Milky Way,
preserving a murmur of an
ancient civilization that
once flourished on a distant
planet. Two hearts on a wing. Very
nice. It's lovely, right? Yeah,
it is.
Although there are six plus
billion earthlings right
now and what the best thing
I think about earth is that
bridge so various, right.
So you can get six plus billion versions
of being an earthlink. Yeah. Like,
if you were any join in Carl Sagan,
what would your recipe of us be?
So we asked a bunch of people
who, a comedian Margaret Show,
uh, you know, her, um, Neil
Gaiman, this graphic novelist,
Michael Cunningham and author, very famous
chef Alice Waters. They all sort of,
you know, told us what they
would send. I'll play you one,
not gonna play all because one, I don't
want to hear it. It would take too long.
You can hear all of them on our website,
actually radiolab.org. But here is, um,
one guy, we asked,
well, this week, you make tiny
little man really surrounded by
thousands upon thousands of people
leading this March. And, uh,
it was so moving.
I think what you'd have to do
is get that piece of footage.
It articulates in this very
simple act, how society's changed,
how people that appear to be powerless
and insignificant can bring about huge
changes.